et gilles simon vous avez été un des
premiers à aller en albanie quelles ont
été vos impressions
bien c'est assez difficile à faire une
comparaison du fait que j étais jamais
allé avant mais enfin j'ai l'impression
c'est un peuple qui est encore très
arriérée où sommes-nous live à tirana
dans une rue tirana une des rues
principales
un couple de paysans étaient venus là
par hasard ou probablement ou qu'il se
rendait au marché sans doute il statue
de staline au milieu d'une grande place
vous êtes resté longtemps
non le sommes mais c'est juste deux
jours vous étiez parti en croisière
revient par le biais des zac te ment et
si vous avez commencé par nous avons
commencé par l'albanie est ensuite alors
là nous sommes allés en mer noire
d'ailleurs là nous sommes en août en
route entre consent à nous avons
débarqué en roumanie et bucarest nous
avions un train c'est le buffet ça
aurait fait comme c'est merveilleux on
joue à la belote sur les rails
ils viennent nous porter ça comme ça
c'est mieux je pense que tu vois si ça
n'est pas gratuit non plus fait dix ans
que nous arrivons là là bucarest la
guerre royal qui est désaffecté
d'ailleurs c'est un honneur pour nous
avait fait sans doute très bon nous
voilà à bucarest
omischl plus ce sont des trams v8 ça
ressemble assez à demeurer
ils sont d'ailleurs assez nombreux parce
qu'il ya très peu de voitures comme vous
pouviez voir s'il n'ya pas non plus de
l'autocar auto d'autobus surtout être
enlevée et partout alors ça celui qui
reste amusant delà de la presse on peut
dire c'est à dire sur une maison on fait
tout ce qui est à prémery reliure les
journaux les hebdomadaires petite église
qu'ils n'ont pas pu visiter elle était
fermée
habituellement ou ce jour là
ce jour là probablement ont fait je n'ai
pas occulter les rues les avenues lui
caresse l'achitecture oui c'est assez
moderne et plus solide séquence courriel
c'est la matière une assez jolie ville
élabore vous voulez vous n'avez aussi
fait que passer à une femme à ces deux
jours seulement le temps de prendre
quelques vues pour nourrir alors fait
c'est très gentil
nous sommes avec vous a piqué est là
avant nous sommes dans le parc staline
dans ce pas staline ils ont édifié un
musée si on veut une rétrospective de la
vie ancienne avec les maisons anciennes
fêtes en bois ou en briques de terre un
vieux moulin
il ya d'ailleurs un lac dans ce palais
où on voit la maison de la presse au
fond au fond si cette fameuse phrase aux
maisons de prêt tout ça est de nouveau
vous reprenez le travail sera pour
constanza et nous traversons la le
danube a soutenu que si souvent chanté
ce qu'il est vraiment bleu trempé les
mêmes très très joli très bateau école
oui c'est un bateau école soviétique
nous arrivons à le port d'odessa l'ayant
très joli c'est un beau pour moi comment
et au dessin odessa est une ville
on pourrait comparer un peu à marseille
c'est un grand port quel accueil vous
avez eu là bas on a eu un accueil très
chaleureux très gentil plus chaleureux
de la part des roumains que les
soviétiques s'ils sont un peu plus froid
pour quelles raisons pensée indifférence
n'ont peut-être pas la différence mais
je crois d'ailleurs que le from un sur
dix par le français alors que le russe
beaucoup moins cet escalier qui
s'assemblent fameux escalier potemkine
oui je le reconnais cette classique
une avenue à odessa le long de la mer ça
c'est assez curieux 700 les tableaux
d'honneur des ouvriers c'est à dire que
chaque semaine ou chaque mois lorsqu'un
ouvrier a fait un rendement supérieur à
la moyenne
il est au tableau d'honneur et alors on
expose sa photographie dans la ville
pendant ce temps les rues de dessins et
serait très peu circulation d'un très
vieux ça le problème dure du parking oui
les acteurs ont cherché le maul problème
du parking et vitré et mériterait à lui
par contre dans les magasins ya foule
comment ça se passe d'abord l'achat à la
vente bien ce gaz 1 ça se passe un peu
comme partout sauf que certains magasins
d'état ne vende certaines choses que
certains jours à bord alors les choses
se passeront tc facilitant les ménagères
puis seulement s'il vend des chaussures
parions qu une seule journée il s'agite
pas loupé l'occasion cette peur venir
fed en lui jouant bien joué
là nous sommes nous sommes à yalta dans
le fameux palais où a eu lieu la
conférence ont fait un staline et
roosevelt une porte en grille en fer
forgé qu'à lire très jolie voilà que ça
fait ma maison blanche sur le balcon
duquel d'ailleurs ils ont eu beaucoup
d'entretiens
c'est joli ça ressemble à une ville
d'agde très grande villa passé à yalta
toujours sur la sur la sur la bord de
l'eau de mer oui leur promenade des
anglais sont possibles oui l'église
orthodoxe
voilà l'intérieur seulement venir
cependant l'intérieur vestibule si on
peut dire parce que l'église était
fermée un moment pas une chance et
pourquoi ont été fermés moi j'ai essayé
de le savoir ne nous a pas un vain mot
c'est écrit en fleurs oui ce sont des
fleurs sont des fleurs sur le site easy
clean des choses gentilles pour tout le
monde est bien c'est de la publicité
avant les cinémas sont amusants mais ce
serait une publicité qui dure assez
longtemps je flirte amusante les fleurs
yeux et beaucoup de monde chef de
magasin ya les petits marchands de glace
enfin [ __ ] codage il a de
particulier ce marchand de glaces par
rapport au nôtre c'est à dire que on
vous délivre un ticket comme dans les
eaux libres ici vous voulez avant j aime
bien son boulot de ne pas contredire
oublie on vous délivre un ticket cetc
nationale y avoir alors le marchand bias
ne gagne pas par rapport à ce qui nous
vend nos jeunes mois par les arrivées
madère ou moins suel ou journalier là
nous arrivions à sophie une ville d'eau
en somme et c'est une des perles de la
mer noire des tons
mais c'était bien pavoiser on nous
attendait la fanfare c'était pour vous
pour vous les les touristes vous aider
pour les touristes en revue son plein
d'intentions c'est gentil comme tout
les montagnes du caucase parce
qu'au-delà de ce film sommes partis en
excursion dans le caucase où la crise a
que je ne citerai joli mais des jeunes
oui c'est un restaurant il a une
particularité ou si je crois
oui en effet c'est là où et comment
dirais je me suis coach fo staline dans
le temps venait sera posée quelquefois
penser des week-ends ou même l'été c'est
un lieu presque historique est ici à là
nous sommes la double michaël hoin lui
revenant yougoslavie marché une
frontière très vite la télévision que
c'est oui l'ancien raguse une très jolie
ville c'est une des c'était la ville
aristocratique les yougoslaves par
excellence dans le temps c'est
d'ailleurs encore une ville très coté
c'est là encore on pourrait dire c'est
leur nid sous leurs cannes si vous
voulez c'est ce que je n'ai pas je vais
vous dire c'est l'impression vraiment
d'être à nice ou à cannes sur le climat
comment est il
le climat est doux il ni trop chaud ni
trop froid galère de la mer sur le
climat est très douce et très agréable
là on est toujours w nous sommes
toujours à tout bref toujours adoré le
général à l'intérieur des remparts parce
que c'est une ville entièrement entourée
de remparts fortifiée elle est solide en
tout cas sur son rock
une impression de force on peut faire le
tour complètement comme à saint malo
paris san et le tour du à pied il faut
compter une heure et demie environ ce
qui vous donne une idée de circonférence
de la ville
oh ça ressemble à l iran pas reconnu
une ruelle et beaucoup de rues en
escalier d'ailleurs de fait la ville et
les construit sur un rocher désanm
yougoslave
elle descendait elles montrent souvent
je crois c'est une petite place une des
rares places
grande pour être en dire parce que ce
sont vraiment les petites rues de quito
n ya pas de circulation du tout derrière
vous êtes très pittoresque s'est référé
voilà spitz nous savons nous sommes avec
leurs idées sur la porte des lions
un marché qui ressemble à beaucoup de
marchés européens
on y vend tout comme vous voyez si bien
des dents telegraph qu'elle est c'est ce
qu'on appelle en appel le colosse de
spitz personnages en bon y côtoie la
fileuse ou l'averse an mais là nous
avons quitté ce prix nous sommes à
trahir une petite ville à quelques
kilomètres de ce titre
ceci s'est amusé à l'intérieur de ce
musée on y découvre les écritures c'est
parait-il sont parmi les plus anciennes
au monde et vous avez pu voir quelque
chose d'intéressant mais pas que non là
on n'a pas vu le wagon dont la visite
est un peu ce musée mais c'est la seule
chose intéressante et nous voilà dans
les gorges de kotor
c'est un fjord d'ailleurs comme saint
siège qui assez profond puisqu'il faut
plus de trois heures les retours de
navigation à l'intérieur des montagnes
de la côte monténégrine
parmi les plus hautes d'ailleurs c'est
très joli et à coup le sol s'est on
dirait c'est assez verdoyant est au bord
de la mer et la couleur de beaucoup de
montagne vers l'est signe enfin vers au
bord de la mer c'est assez verdoyant et
de temps en temps au vu des petits
villages comme celui ci dont celui ci
sont vraiment sur la mer ah oui tous les
pieds dans l'eau quoi exactement
oui on longe très près parce que par
endroits le le fjord est très étroit
wifi nature est juste heureux remous
votre bateau les gîtes et les autres
aussi deux petites îles là sur lesquels
il ya un monastère munster forum pour un
parrainage chaque avant un seul sac et
c'est très bien ça